in this capsule we go and translate the
notion of probability distribution
then a probability destruction is
simply the enumeration of
probabilities for all values
possible that can take one or
several random variables with
examples here for example the distribution
of probabilities for the reverra thouars
spamming community with a country in
bold then in parentheses the symbol the
name of the random variable it's going to be
enumeration of all priorities
for all possible values ​​of
pits so when on both
possible values
we will have the numbers of the
rotten politics on the equal should the
spam policy equals true is
a way of presenting them that
I use here in the form of a table
awards a list where we insert the
the set of marginal probabilities
for marc arabic oratory we can have
productive distributions on
several random variables nas that
if they are you or in this case what we
gets it's a table in two
dimensions finally so this chart
lens will contain all the
probabilities for all assignments
possible of everything but random variable
because if rotten to the same wrong
unknown there is the need for yaya the true
unknown
Galfond Spam Equals Fake Unknowns He
there is the true power there is the true is
also known to note that the sum
on all my enumeration all my
table always worth is equal to 1 that's
a property the fundamental of
probability distributions it
be 1 and then marked so I use
pedro symbol for distributions that
I will use the symbol peace in
italic for a probability
individual and among others a
notation that I will sometimes used cp
of spam but where peace and italics
and dense that if I will actually designated
a spurious probability equals x but
for a slab in 2x that I will not
specified so for a value of x
anyway in fact so pipe of
spams in italics it may be
do any part of my
distribution of quarries
finally and notice that the choice
to list the priorities in a table
or late from the minister no matter it's a
little arbitrary did the general concept
of a distribution it's just
enumeration of priorities for
all possible values ​​of but
random variable we can have
also distributions
conditional or in condition on
some random variables by
compared to other slaughterhouse
so for example we would have the
distribution of spam knowing that a
unknown there is the truth that's what there
enumeration of spam priorities
and galfond and rot legal true in
both cases knowing that unknown equals
cool then we could also not
specify the possible value of
unknown so we're queen a section
conditional which in this case this is
one of the rations of 4 probability for
ja fake legal knowing that a known it
must to irrigate the true knowing that
knew there is the need to go there
false gallons knowing that has known galls
true to go what a true that everyone
known fresh galls and in this case
in my psychological kind present under the
form of a table in two dimensions
each of my ranger go summit to 1
so in fact every subset of
associated probabilities have even variable
have even value variables for
which I condition must summit
to 1 in a conditional distribution
in other words the disruption
conditional on knowing spam
unknown we can see on how to do
2.2 distribution not useful on the
spam variable one has one for the
unknown body wales need more one for
the equal unknown body would do so we have
two because a stranger near valence
then obviously if unknown time
discrete random variable of long
would have as much distribution in front of
the possible for unknown
a little remark about conceptually
comment on what we can understand
conditional distributions in fact one
can see them as a distribution that
is unconditional but we have
standardized regret differently for that
in this case we satisfy the
summation conditions to 1 for
different variable codes
random on which I condition
so for example the distribution of
spam that everyone knows true Wales
by definition it's actually you like it
pro liter marginal spam is
unknown but / a constant of
normalization which is such that in fact I
am going to get a little option that will
so I'm going to arrive the variable
random for nothing so
but enjoy marginal spam equal
because if you need a fairy tale
is for nothing equals true unknown
true galls are given here since that
must summit at 1
it needs alpha to match the sum
of those two numbers there as I read here
so finally finally got got
my conditional distribution of
sacha spam is known gallerey
it's just taking the pro liter
marginal spam and unknown there is the
true and then read normalized for that
rings at 1 and in case I specify
not the value of a stranger
Well, it's a little bit the same but
the player two constants of
different normalization one for the
equal unknown body needs one for
the unknown and gavray and so I have my
two marginal probability for y is
legal is necessary to get there the truth that I
divide by the sum to get a
distribution in each case the case
here is known calfo then the quasi
unknown in real who are 1